[Music]
in no shame news chane submitted by
Moses from London High Bible guy it's a
video of a woman stealing tips from her
uber driver has gone viral
oh I saw this all over Instagram
question let's go Beyonce question I'm
not saying that looks have anything to
do with anything in this world but she
got titties oh she's hot
titties is she hot I just go finish your
thought is she hot
I think so books have everything to do
it but I wouldn't call her heart oh but
that me she's not ugly because you
didn't call her cute if you call their
cute that she'd be [ __ ] ugly I don't
think she's cute either okay then what
is she what she yeah
I'll show you okay so this this takes
place in New York City this video was
posted by the uber driver he said that
he didn't contact the police for
whatever reason he was just too busy
getting going
I love idiom R is negligible it really
was this girl's saying that I was five
bucks but the uber driver does not
confirm how much exactly it was so I'll
show you guys the video right now this
[ __ ] said it was just five bucks yes
she said that works yeah yes it's even
worse cuz that's like stealing 25 cents
she's like don't shred I just stole a
little bit yeah that's fine I just
punched it claims that she gave it back
to the uber driver but that the driver
hasn't confirmed that fact oh yeah oh so
right here you'll see that there's the
tip door in the center was she weren't
just the top it's only a bra she's
wearing a bra and a skirt see that's why
it looked like she had big boobs oh my
god she looks like it looks yeah yeah
yeah they're not that big huh it I
thought it was in my memory because
she's only in a bra
yeah yeah so like if she had an actual
shirt on her boobs are gonna look
smallest so what happened to her shirt
her shirt she needed to buy another one
that's why she stopped where's the bra
here we go
the bra was backwards - he looks like
keegan-michael key she got her stomachs
talking old a ninja turtle mouth oh yeah
what she's looking into the camera
no she's looking at the premiere -
making sure that his head oh damn that's
[ __ ] up oh my god I would snap what
about it friends friendship position
what would you do Bart damn it's tough
when it comes to girls and crows who is
your guy in the group yeah I would [ __ ]
the dude up I just don't know what to do
in a girl but I would just [ __ ] I would
beat the living [ __ ] out of you have you
ever said that to somebody though what
were if a girl like a girl pissed you
off but she has a guy it's like you keep
on talking I'm a [ __ ] your guy
no but that's one thing in my head hmm
you know what girl that's more to that
the guys there then the guy is guilty by
association
yeah that's what it is yeah she's he's
with them yeah you know edrick right
yeah so a jerk we were all at that one
that late-night spot that everybody goes
to a cake down that Korean joint so
Dottie hold it okay so so this girl or
modern Olympic like we're all children
and we're all just calm or whatever and
this girl just looks at me and she goes
hey you're that funny guy right and
she's clearly drunk right and she goes
why don't you tell me a joke right
whatever what now she does and she grabs
Adric it she's like shaking edrick he
goes hey you're is your friend like the
funniest guy in the world is he like
she's drunk it's drunk hey drunk and she
doesn't like being touched like that
he's like his auntie he's the funniest
guy the roadways a funny guy he goes
well you're a [ __ ] terrible friend
and then she starts throwing ice chips
at the back of all oh my god I just get
a [ __ ] manage me Edric cleveland
they're like a couple other guys and it
was her like three girls and then one
guy and all of us just looked and we
looked at the guy
he goes stop I'm about to ask ya cuz we
can't hit you we'll beat the [ __ ] out of
that dude yeah you mean it was just like
what are those that you wage is like
this is a good situation cuz there's
somebody we could actually let our
aggression out on yeah but it was like
so ridiculous I was like huh that guy
must feel really terrible right now I
would just record it cuz when they're
sober they're gonna pay for it by
feeling like a fool just beat the guys
face me too you would you tackle a
double leg takedown or I probably just
grabbed the top of his head and just
start pounding a minute about his basin
yeah out of his pants like that and
separate his dick from his balls oh
you'd strip him down and just grab his
nut so scary what about his hands though
they're free elbows homeys elbows they
got the they're gonna scarecrow his ass
then the driver he contacted uber and
uber the campaign quote we understand
your frustration with this experience
we've attempted to contact the writer by
phone and email but haven't been able to
resolve this issue
the writer responded to us and advised
us that she didn't steal your cash from
the tip jar if you believe the writer
has your cash as captured from your dash
cam and is refusing to return it you may
want to initiate a formal investigation
via the police which he says he didn't
because he was too busy working to do
that so that's when he and this video
online and then went viral and then so
for a while we didn't know that this
person was but then all of a sudden that
this girl she ends up posting on
snapchat she ends up posting this on
snapchat someone commented on her
Instagram saying this is right after you
stole the money from that uber driver
hope you get jailed and she responds
saying actually this was before I left
my house but his little $5 was returned
when it happened three months ago lol
but never was the type for jail and so
they're commenting on this photo where
she's wearing this same outfit from that
day and so she's claiming that she
returned the money but we don't know
that so trick photography
my stomach was talking like a
[ __ ] that [ __ ] looked like
hamburger buns [ __ ] did one of these
things to [ __ ] press her titty
against and then she put one leg in
front of the other
she got some blame shame she's like see
the food you could tell her ass is not
there yeah nonexistent you kind of you
could see the song if the songs aligned
disappeared that means she's got the
bubble butt mmm baba baba but she
doesn't have the bubble she doesn't get
the bubble that's that you could see the
lot she knows like witchcraft or some
sort yeah she needs to barge she's 18 18
you look terrible for 82 a good solid 32
- and I'm 34 I don't even look that old
no no you you're gonna do that give or
take yeah so then she also posted this
on her snapchat will do this screenshot
of Daily Mail's snapchat so she's famous
so she put for stealing she put my life
last my ass off hashtag make smart
choices and they she also wrote Spanish
mommy book gangs five dollars and gets
caught and is exposed three months later
so absolutely this all happened in
August she's proud of it yes she doesn't
give a [ __ ] and then finally she got
interviewed and I bet her mom's proud of
her she in one of the interview she ends
up saying like well I'm not sorry why am
I gonna fake being sorry and being
synthetic I'm just like you could be a
decent human being and be remorseful
yeah you were there you could have done
something to her what would you do that
bark cuz bark can't do it but you could
do something cuz you could probably do
some you should spank her and then we
could record it so we could Amelia her
chokehold
yeah I mean I would have got the running
back like Howl's oh I would have ran out
there would you grab her drive my ankle
sort of faces scraping against the UH
asphalt I don't know I mean I'm not
really violin if I get what I want
immediately then that's it like what if
she doesn't get so on that [ __ ] right
that's wrapping swipe you're coming up
after me I'm like with that thang
are you
what are you like the [ __ ]
five-dollar police you [ __ ] top [ __ ]
yeah yeah I'm getting my I'm getting
what I want
oh no you're not getting your back [ __ ]
unless you [ __ ] whup my ass then I
move your ass oh really you're gonna
whup my ass well let's get [ __ ] butt
naked I did that I went so when we were
in Australia um I think it was the end
of the performance you know we used to
sell merch yeah and I was running that
and then there was like a bunch of
people like just walking by and then one
of the shirts disappeared I was like oh
I think I told you guys I was like I
think so no so I just went after that
girl I grabbed that she was like what
the [ __ ] are you doing is she's just
like a bottom come on okay push your
head to the side no I don't need to
because it's that's all I want
I saw a bird [ __ ] if she was my friend
I'll be like I know your friend no more
no but this happened oh but you're at
the uber driver stole from you a girl
well if you would have grabbed her like
while she was taking it is that a soul
like let's say she was like go like that
and you grabbed her wrist is that who's
that boy don't let him commit the crime
first I think ah well I mean you're
citizen to prevent the crime though - I
mean it's tricky I got the camera right
the camera's not rolling
yeah but the cameras were rolling I'm
tired she was going to grab it and you
great you happen to grab it at the same
time her wrist that's rape in California
cuz for me as at Lubert Ivor I don't
know how much money I'm making but tips
are a big thing it's human you try to
take away my life Luber drivers were
accepting actual cash tips though they
had tip jars nothing yeah no nothing I
was a girl I will catch her and her
other friend and then we will all make
out we don't realize how off it is until
you laugh more like you're right that's
like just cuz you ads if I was a girl
what I do yeah it's very different but
it's his fault too if he had one the
protectors it's not his fault
no but you know at McDonald's
have they had that thing yeah yeah yes
look at the top where you could put it
doesn't come back so they what she would
have to like she couldn't do that you
know what I always want this is a young
person if somebody stole my [ __ ] which I
never would do because I don't have the
strength for it nor a micro Aegis enough
if somebody did that I hope to just take
him to the floor stand on their back
shoulder get their arm and just go rock
this [ __ ] drumstick off a chicken
yeah I just snap that [ __ ] arm I bet
you that feels so satisfying
I have Chiropractic dreams too I don't
know about you guys but I feel like
around 18 ish though I would do
something stupid like that with my
friends or like I would have friends
like that and then I will kind of laugh
about it I think I would get mad if they
didn't share that money with me yeah so
I you know what how bad has her home
life and her upbringing for her to be
such a scoundrel at 18 years old and
she's [ __ ] thirsting for come like
that like there's something going on
right yeah I think I don't it's not our
position to understand what her past
history is my position is that she's a
piece of [ __ ] and she looks really
really old
[Music]
you
[Music]